ينضم الينا من بيروت وزير الداخليه
والبلديات بسام المولوي اهلا وسهلا بك
معالي الوزير سابدا من المعطيات الاخيره
حول عمليه الخطف اين هو المواطن السعودي
الان ما المعطيات والتفاصيل حول هذه
العمليه خصوصا اننا يعني نتابع الكثير من
من التفاصيل التي ليست محسومه ما كانت
رسميه ام لا
مساء الخير
القوه الامنيه
ولا سيما شعبه المعلومات في قوى الامن
الداخلي وكافه القوه الامنيه تتابع منذ
البارحه
هذا الموضوع هذا الموضوع مهم هذا الموضوع
دقيق جدا هذا الموضوع تتابعه القوى
الامنيه بكل حرفيه ومهنيه
ويجري التواصل بطبيعه الحال مع السفير
السعودي مع معالي السفير وليد البخاري
لاجل متابعه الموضوع ولاجل اطلاعه على ما
يلزم من تفاصيل وعلى ما
تحصل عليه القوى الامنيه نحن علينا متابعه
الموضوع هذا موضوع لا نقبل به هذا موضوع
يمس بعلاقه لبنان بالدول العربيه الشقيقه
ونسيمه بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه ان امن
وامان كافه المقيمين على الاراضي
اللبنانيه ولا سيما المواطنين العرب
والمواطنين من من مواطني دول الخليج
العربي ومواطنين المملكه العربيه
هم اشقاء وان امنهم وامانهم مهم جدا
للبنان ولعلاقته ولعلاقه لبنان بهذه الدول
الشقيقه اننا نتابع الموضوع منذ البارحه
اننا تابعنا ونتابع الموضوع طوال الليل
الماضي وطوال اليوم
اننا نتابع حركه الاتصالات نتابع حركه
كاميرا
كاميرات المراقبه الممتده في بيروت وفي
محيطها واكثر ابعد من ذلك على الاراضي
اللبنانيه ان اخذ تفاصيل عن ما توصلتم
اليه حتى الساعه اعلم ان هناك بعض
التفاصيل امنيا لا يمكن الحديث عنها ولكن
المعطيات بحسب يعني الزملاء في بيروت بان
تم رصد هاتف
المختطف بثلاث نقاط تم ارسال منها رسائل
بالساعات الماضيه من اي منطقه خطف هل فعلا
الخاطفين كانوا بذي عسكري واوهموه بانهم
من القوى الامنيه
طالما انت تقولين ان المعلومات لديك او
لدى
الاعلام تقول بانه تم رصد
مكالمات او رسائل هاتفيه من اكثر من منطقه
هذا يعني ان
هاتف المواطن السعودي يتنقل بين اكثر من
منطقه في بيروت وهذا يدل على
عمل معين لدى الفاعلين وهذا يستوجب على
القوى الامنيه اللبنانيه ان تكون على قدر
كبير من الحيطه ومن الحذر وان تتعامل مع
الموضوع بدقه بالغه
ينبغي لسلامه التحقيق
ولسريه التحقيق الواجبه للوصول الى نتيجه
ولسلامه المواطن السعودي طبعا وهي الاهم
ان نلتزم بحد معين من سريه التحقيق
لجلاء كافه الملابسات طالما كما تقولين ان
الفاعلين يتنقلون بالهاتف المنطقه الى
اخرى ضمن بيروت او يمكن بيروت فهذا
الموضوع
ضمن بيروت ومحيط بيروت هل فعلا يعني وصل
الى ظهر البيدر هل ممكن الحديث عن انه
اصبح خارج بيروت
لا لا لا نحن لا يمكن ان نؤكد مثل هذه
المعلومه انما كاميرات المراقبه
تفيدنا بكل التفاصيل من كل مكان في لبنان
حتى
انت تقولين انها تم رصد شيء معين في في
كاميرا في ظهر البيدر هذا دليل على ان
القوى الامنيه تتابع الموضوع بشكل جيد اما
ما قلتيه عن ان الخاطفين يرتدون هذه
العسكري فهذه معلومه
لا نستطيع ان نؤكدها بل هي لم ترد الينا
بهذه الصوره
واننا نتابع الموضوع بسريه وبدقه وبحرفيه
وبمهنيه وطبعا من واجبنا طالما الموضوع
يتعلق بمواطن سعودي ان نحيط السفير
السعودي وان نعمل معا لسلامه المواطن
السعودي
ولم تهت م به السفاره السعوديه
ومعالي السفير وليد البخاري شخصيا بما
يتعلق بسلامه المواطن السعودي هذا الموضوع
هو من واجبنا هذا الموضوع نعم
حسب يعني معطياتنا ام اعلم بانك لا تريد
ان تدخل بالتفاصيل كثيرا ولكن نحن مضطرين
ان ناخذ يعني على الاقل شيء من كل الاخبار
التي تخرج لمعرفه دقه هذه الاخبار مصادرنا
في بيروت تقول بان سياره المواطن السعودي
وجدت في البقاع وبالتالي بان المخطوف تم
نقله من بيروت الى البقاع ومن هنا تم رصد
الهاتف باخر يعني باخر مره تم فتحه فيها
عن بظهر البيتر هل فعلا وجدت السياره في
البقاع
يعني مع التحفظ على المعلومات وعلى انه
يجب ان نحفظ السريه لكل السياره لم لم
يعثر على السياره في البقاع ولم يرصد
الهاتف في منطقه ظهر البيدر هذا غير صحيح
هذا غير صحيح
حتى الان
[موسيقى]
نحن نحن نتابع الموضوع
وسيتضح قريبا وجليا الهدف من العمليه
والمهم بالنسبه الينا كشف كافه كافه
الخيوط
والعثور على المواطن السعودي سليما باذن
الله حتى اليوم يمكن القول بان يعني
المواطن السعودي بصحه جيده هو بخير هو
بمكان يعني بحسب كل الحركه التي رستموها
بالساعات الماضيه وهل فعلا تم رفض هاتفه
بالضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت
تم رصد الهاتف بامكنه مختلفه ضمن بيروت
وضواحيها وليس في الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت
لم يتم رصد حركه هاتف في الضاحيه الجنوبيه
لبيروت
انما ما يرصد من الهاتف
وفي عده مناطق والتنقل في عده مناطق يدل
على ان المواطن السعودي مازال بخير
نعمل ان تتمكن القوى الامنيه من ان تجده
قريبا
خطف نهار السبت بالتحقيقات التي قمتم بها
مع يعني ان كان الجيران او ان كان
الاصدقاء بالمنطقه التي يقيم فيها الى
ماذا خلصت حتى الساعه وهل يعني كان ابلغ
فتره عن اي تحرك او اي احد يعني
حاول ان يستدرجه الى مكان ما
الاختفاء حصل فجر الاحد واننا نتابع
التحقيقات منذ ذلك الحين ان جيرانه في
مكان اقامته في عرمون لم يدلوا باي
معلومات تتعلق بانه قد تعرض لاي تهديد نحن
نتابع الموضوع بدقه نحن
على اتصال دائم مع سفاره المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ونسيمه مع سعاده السفير مع علي
السفير وليد البخاري
ان الفاعل سوف يلقى جزاءه لن نترك مثل هذه
الجريمه تمر لن نترك موضوع اختفاء مواطن
سعودي على الاراضي اللبنانيه يمر دون حساب
الحساب يجب ان يكون جديا وقاسيا ورادعا
ير الوزير يعني
تحدثت بان هذه العمليه ليست بالتفصيل
وبانها تاتي في خضم يعني سياق بشع جدا وهي
تؤثر بطريقه كبيره وتاثير كبير على
العلاقات اللبنانيه السعوديه واللبنانيه
العربيه ماذا ستقومون من تدابير بهذا
الاطار خصوصا وان هذه العمليه ممكن ان
تؤثر ايضا على البحث بالمستقبل عن عمليه
عوده السياح
والزوار العرب الى بيروت
الموضوع يتعلق بالامن والامان في لبنان
الموضوع يتجاوز مساله السياحه ويتجاوز
مساله الاصطياف الى الاهتمام بالامن
والامان للبنانيين ولكل المقيمين على
الاراضي اللبنانيه ولا سيما منهم الاشقاء
العرب وبالاخص الاشقاء السعوديين عمل
القوه الامنيه الجيد والدؤوب لكشف تفاصيل
لكشف التفاصيل
ومصداقيتنا
لدى الشعب اللبناني ولد الاشقاء العرب ولا
سيما الاشقاء السعوديين تؤكد بان مثل هذه
الحادثه لا يمكن ان تؤثر على علاقه لبنان
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه وعلى اهتمام
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بلبنان وبشؤون
لبنان فالمملكه العربيه السعوديه لم تترك
لبنان ولن تتركه ونحن لم ننقطع ولم تنقطع
علاقتنا بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه من هنا
ومن هنا ومن
منطلق واجباتنا وواجبنا
نهتم بالموضوع ونتابع الموضوع وسنصل الى
نتيجه
ولا نترك هذا هذه الحادثه تمر مرورا سريعا
او تمر دون عقاب مهما كان الامر شكرا لك
وزير الداخليه اللبناني بسام المولوي على
وجودك معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات